por qué
[Música]
ah
los casos de inseguridad repuntan en
ecuador en el episodio más reciente un
artefacto explosivo fue detonado en un
barrio popular de la ciudad de guayaquil
que es el principal puerto de este país
suramericano sobre el pacífico cinco
personas perdieron la vida y otras 16
resultaron heridas las autoridades
todavía están evaluando los daños
causados por esta detonación veamos
terror en guayaquil los narcos
evolucionan sus métodos disparos y una
fuerte explosión resultado muertos
heridos y desaparecidos también ocho
casas destruidas el presidente guillermo
lasso anunció medidas en twitter he
declarado en estado de excepción a la
ciudad de guayaquil debido a los sucesos
delictivos dados en las últimas horas se
dispondrá de toda la fuerza pública para
restablecer el control de la ciudad no
permitiremos que el crimen organizado
pretenda manejar al país el suceso tuvo
lugar en el barrio del cristo del
consuelo a las dos de la madrugada una
moto lanzó una bolsa con explosivos y
sintió muy fuerte fue yo pensé que era
que estaba temblando en la tierra lo
primero porque o sea la cama se movió un
remezón y esto sí yo cogí amigo lo jale
con angustia el bebé y me iba a salir
corriendo como loca pero me calme ya y
me quedé y ahí dice aunque no queda bien
la medida que había tirado en la calle 8
la policía investiga y busca información
ofrecen 10 mil dólares de recompensa
desde el primer atentado con explosivos
contra civiles
se degrada día a día eso va de mal en
peor
o sea multiplica la situación guayaquil
vive a una ola de violencia por el
control del narcotráfico es el epicentro
de américa latina' para la exportación
de cocaína la tasa de homicidios por
100.000 habitantes en ecuador ha pasado
de 6 a 14 desde 2018 el reflejo de la
situación se ve en las prisiones donde
más de 350 personas han sido asesinadas
en disputas entre bandas
como lo veíamos el presidente guillermo
lasso declaró entonces el estado de
excepción pero muchos critican esta
medida dado que no resuelve o busca
resolver el problema de raíz cuál es
entonces el problema de raíz pues el
aumento de los grupos delincuenciales y
las disputas entre ellos por un tema de
fondo y en común el narcotráfico qué
papel entonces juega guayaquil en el
eslabón de las rutas de distribución de
los cárteles de la droga en suramérica
que tan permeada está permeado está el
narcotráfico en la dinámica ciudadana en
la dinámica de este importante puerto
del pacífico que dicen las autoridades
que dice la policía ya cayeron en las
redes de corrupción cuando el principal
puerto de ecuador como lo decíamos
guayaquil en el pacifico pasó a ser un
punto importante del narcotráfico y de
la delincuencia común la violencia y la
inseguridad ganan terreno en la ciudad
de guayaquil y por eso lo analizamos en
esta edición del debate de france 24
para conversar sobre este tema saludamos
a karla álvarez velasco ella es
especialista en temas de seguridad
ella se conecta desde la ciudad de quito
desde la capital ecuatoriana se conecta
a carolina andrada de ellas analista
política también analista de temas de
seguridad e inteligencia
les recuerda que ustedes hacen parte de
esta conversación pueden a participar a
través de sus preguntas y comentarios en
nuestras redes sociales estamos en
twitter de instagram en facebook en
donde no se encuentran como france24
bajo ese arroba santi logo que es mi
cuenta personal de etiqueta numeral el
debate efe 24 en youtube también pueden
seguir nuestra señal en streaming y
también aprovecho para saludar a las
personas que nos están escuchando a
través de nuestro podcast todos los
contenidos del debate ya están
disponibles en diferentes plataformas en
app el podcast en spotify deezer y
tuning
salud entonces en la ciudad de quito a
karla álvarez velasco para comenzar
conociendo posiciones relacionados sobre
este tema carla bienvenida al programa y
mi punto de partida para el éxito una
declaración que dio el gobierno nacional
de ecuador después de estos hechos que
se registraron en guayaquil en los
últimos días dijeron que este atentado
en guayaquil era una declaratoria de
guerra por parte del crimen organizado
me pregunta entonces es esta el estado
de ecuador en guerra contra el crimen
organizado cuál es su opinión
más adelante me escuche si perfecto me
voy a usted
muy bien
si sueño pero yo me preguntaba le repito
la pregunta
si el perfecto adelante
sí bueno en el ecuador está en guerra
con el narcotráfico sí desde hace un
tiempo
los índices de criminalidad han venido
subiendo
progresivamente de manera muy rápida y
el ecuador definitivamente ha entrado
como en uno en una pugna con el
narcotráfico que además para la cual no
ha tenido una estrategia consistente
entonces por una parte del estado está
en guerra está buscando contener la
salida de droga por el país por el
territorio ecuatoriano pero por otra
parte no tiene una estrategia
contundente esto ha generado por una
parte claro una presión sobre los grupos
que están peleando por sacar la droga
que están peleando por tener ganancias
por poder ubicar sus
alcaloides digamos la cocaína en este
caso en los mercados de consumo pero por
otra parte pues han logrado evadir de
alguna manera los controles estatales
también han logrado permear a las
autoridades oa las fuerzas de control y
entonces esto
muchísimo el panorama porque
estamos teniendo como un embate del
narcotráfico que además tiene un repunte
después de la pandemia a partir de la
pandemia y el estado ha hecho lo que ha
podido lo que ha intuido que puede hacer
claro no ha tenido una estrategia
contundente y esto ha generado una
explosión de violencia
carolina de punto de partida para este
debate para conocer posiciones la misma
pregunta está el gobierno del ecuador el
estado ecuatoriano en una una guerra
declarada contra el crimen organizado y
contra el narcotráfico cuál es su punto
de vista
hola buenos dias santiago un gusto
saludarlo creo que bueno hay varios
factores del ecuador y ya de por si
estaba situado geográficamente entre el
maíz los mayores productores de cocaína
el último informe de naciones unidas
habla de un incremento del 11 por ciento
de la producción global de cocaína con
corte el año 2020 el año de la pandemia
entonces ya teníamos este factor que iba
a estar ahí permanentemente sin embargo
a partir de 2017 el sector seguridad
sufre un desmantelamiento institucional
se reducen capacidades tanto a nivel
institucional como también a nivel
humano técnico y tecnológico del sector
seguridad vinculados al sistema de
inteligencia del sistema de
investigaciones o sea el no está en este
momento el estado ecuatoriano preparado
para dar una respuesta además de eso
vemos un estado totalmente reactivo sin
capacidad de poder prevenir con tareas
de inteligencia y poder realizar
investigaciones especiales entonces
claro el camino del actual gobierno ha
sido esta idea de declarar la guerra al
narcotráfico como una especie de
polarización entre buenos y malos cuando
no busca abordar los temas de fondo
venimos insistiendo en la necesidad de
generar más acciones en el eje de
prevención a bordo en el sector social
las causas de fondo el crimen organizado
encuentre espacio cuando existe un
estado ausente que no es capaz de
incluir un presente y un futuro para los
ecuatorianos
carolina continuó con usted para hacer
la ronda en sentido contrario y quiero
ir al punto de origen de esta situación
de usted lo decía que ecuador era un
productor de
alcaloides en diferentes momentos de su
historia reciente pero en qué momento en
guayaquil comenzó a salirse las manos de
las autoridades en qué momento guayaquil
pasó a ser un punto importante en esa
cadena de distribución del narcotráfico
no sé si mundial pero por lo menos de la
por lo menos de la área suramericana
y en donde llegan a actuar carteles de
colombia de méjico perú incluso de
bolivia y brasil en qué momento
guayaquil se le salió a las autoridades
fue en el gobierno de correa fue antes
del gobierno de correa o esto es algo
más reciente
bueno primero y mencionar que el ecuador
no produce cocaína nosotros dentro del
rol que cumple el estado que el país
ecuador dentro de la cadena de
suministro de las economías criminales
vinculados al narcotráfico es más un rol
de paso de almacenamiento y de envío de
la droga hacia mercados internacionales
en este en este sentido las provincias
de en frontera como esmeraldas pero
también mandaría el caso de guayas con
guayaquil con el puerto de guayaquil
tienen sus roles distribuidos no dentro
de estas economías criminales esmeraldas
también ha incrementado muchísimo el
tema de violencia inseguridad y también
se han suscitado en esta provincia
limítrofe con colombia muy cercana no es
cierta lo que es la zona de tu marco
también eventos con artefacto de
explosivos ahora guayaquil también
siempre ha sido una ciudad considerada
muy insegura muy violenta en este
momento varias de las hipótesis que
podemos mantener es una que existe un
alto almacenamiento de droga alrededor
del cuerpo de guayaquil por eso es que
estamos observando acciones vinculadas a
parroquias loa barrios cercanos al
puerto donde podría estar almacenada una
alta no pudo salir durante la pandemia
pero también vemos que en el medio de la
crisis de contenedores que existe a
nivel del comercio internacional tampoco
ha podido salir esa droga durante los
últimos años por lo cual genera mayor
presión dentro de las tareas de
seguridad y de precautelar que saludas
no sea identificada por parte de las
autoridades eso es otro tema que está
ahí pero también tenemos un alto número
de homicidios y de violencia criminal en
esta zona que ha sido de alta
vulnerabilidad soy en cuanto a sus
poblaciones a nivel socioeconómico en
carla pasó a preguntarle a usted también
la relación de quito quienes son los que
actúan que hay cabecillas identificados
en este grupo en estos diferentes grupos
al margen de la ley que están operando
allí en guayaquil que se sabe de la
estructura de estos grupos que vemos que
tienen disputas
tanto en las calles de la ciudad en los
barrios marginales de la ciudad pero
también al interior de las prisiones en
diferentes puntos de ecuador hemos visto
la crisis carcelaria que ha tenido este
país en los últimos meses que se sabe
qué información hay en cuanto a esas
estructuras a esos cabecillas quienes
los lideran y si esto está permeado por
influencia del exterior hablo de
carteles de colombia o de mexico
bueno se conoce que hay varios grupos
criminales hay un punto hace un par de
años se
se acabó con la vida de uno de los
cabecillas más importantes de una de las
bandas que se llama los choneros que
generó como una fragmentación de las de
las pandillas y de los grupos criminales
en el ecuador y a partir de eso no han
logrado los choneros más logrados como
reconstituir su su estructura de poder y
esta fragmentación lo que ha hecho es
permitir que aparezcan muchas bandas
pequeñas grandes con distintas
capacidades que pongan por el territorio
el problema es que no tenemos en una
configuración de bandas criminales al
estilo cartel de cali cartel de medellín
que eran bandas
carteles claramente identificados con
estructuras y claras verticales digamos
en este caso no son grupos pequeñitos
son grupos muy fragmentados que además
tienen acceso a recursos como armas
tienen acceso al dinero que proviene del
tráfico y de otras actividades ilegales
entonces pues tenemos un panorama
complejo en la medida que no se tiene
identificada la cantidad de bandas que
existen tienen están en pelea entre
ellos y han logrado hay momentos tienen
alianzas en por otros momentos se
dividen entonces es un panorama complejo
ya pero aún así siendo difícil leerlos
se conoce que pues han tenido han
logrado
infiltrar a la fuerza pública han
logrado infiltrar a algunas
instituciones del estado para lograr
sacar su mercadería y para cometer otros
delitos el narcotráfico no es el único
delito que enfrenta este momento el
ecuador tampoco es el más importante es
el más visible y el que mayor uso
político tiene tal vez entonces vemos
que la situación del ecuador claro no
está y no está amenazado el país
únicamente por el narco sino por otros
delitos y esto tiene que ver con lo que
decía carolina la
desinstitucionalización del estado en
materia de seguridad
fragilidad que tiene y esto permite pues
la operación de estas bandas pequeñas
que tienen poder que tienen recursos y
que están afectando a la población y que
nos empiezan a poner en una situación de
caos y de mucha complejidad ya vamos a
hablar de ese punto importante que lo
tocan ustedes dos el tema del gobierno y
de esta lucha que está tratando de hacer
por como decían ustedes no de una forma
preventiva sino reactiva y como se le ha
dado paso o se le ha cedido terreno en
cierta forma para que estos grupos
delincuenciales tomen un poco más de
fuerza quiero preguntarle algo en carla
y es un punto que usted mencionaba las
estructuras usted dice que estos grupos
carecen de unas grandes estructuras como
los grandes carteles que uno puede ver
en méxico o que hubo en colombia en los
80 y en los 90
esto
que esté como tan atomizado en esta zona
del pacífico ecuatoriano dificulta aún
más
y poderlos combatir por parte del estado
esto que es tan estratégico puede ser
que se mantenga como una una
organización sin estructura o que sean
simplemente porque son pequeños grupos
que están tomando fuerza poco a poco
porque cada vez están tomando más fuerza
pues esto presenta una dificultad enorme
porque no hay que seguir a un grupo o no
hay que seguir a una organización sino
que en el caso de ecuador hay que seguir
a múltiples organizaciones con alianzas
inestables excesivamente volátiles que
además no están solo concentradas en el
puerto de guayaquil que es como una de
las caras visibles de la violencia están
dispersados por todo el territorio y
tienen muchísima actividad en las zonas
de frontera en la frontera norte
mencionada carolina en otros puertos que
hay en el país pero están actuando con
muchísima violencia hay el número de
muertes por cada 100.000 habitantes en
distintas regiones del país ha
incrementado enormemente porque están en
la disputa sobre los puertos los pasos
primero los pasos del territorio y
después los puertos de salida de la
droga en este sentido en buscar las
estructuras de estos cabecillas o de las
organizaciones criminales mismo pues es
complejo para un estado que desarticuló
su inteligencia para un estado que no
tiene una coordinación entre las
instituciones entonces mientras ellos
actúan con muchísima flexibilidad
son muy aptos para cambiar para tomar
nuevas actitudes pues el estado actúa
con muchísima lentitud y con poca
coordinación entonces se vuelve a un
terreno muy fértil para que
distintas de distintas maneras los
grupos quieran y puedan lucrar y llegar
a un claro círculo vicioso lo que se
está presentando allí carolina también
retomo uno de los puntos que usted tocó
en su intervención anterior y es la
ausencia del estado o la poca presencia
del estado para entender qué es lo que
está sucediendo allí creo que es
importante explicarle a la audiencia
fuera de las fronteras de ecuador cuál
es el panorama social de esta ciudad en
particular de guayaquil un puerto muy
importante es la segunda ciudad más
importante de ecuador después de quito
pero de las zonas donde ellos actúan
bueno ustedes han dicho que hay
presencia en diferentes puntos del
del país pero principalmente allí cuál
es la situación social que lleva a que
las personas tengan como su mejor opción
de medio de subsistencia meterse a ser
parte de un grupo delincuencial de éstos
bueno en la costa en general y guayas
específicamente como jackie siempre ha
sido una zona de alta vulnerabilidad
socio-económica por ejemplo el lugar
donde cedió la detonación ayer de la
perfecto explosivo en cristo del
consuelo es una zona construida mediante
invasiones una zona históricamente
construida mediante invasiones donde la
población tiene un alto consumo de
drogas pero también se trafica mucha
droga donde existe una población muy
importante a pretoriana que ha migrado
ya de provincias del norte como
esmeraldas y se ha localizado en esta
zona como podemos ver las mañas es
justamente se encuentra en el lado del
estero salado donde permite una vía de
comunicación también con lo que es el
puerto de guayaquil una zona de alta
vulnerabilidad donde el estado no tiene
una presencia efectiva no hay el sector
social ahí no es encuentran lo cierto en
servicios públicos de salud educación se
subestima completamente el tema de salud
pública en cuanto a consumo de drogas y
claro todos estos temas confluyen a
dejar abierto un paso libre para que las
organizaciones criminales sean la opción
la única opción en muchos casos para
poblaciones vulnerables
construirse un espacio de vida o un
espacio un significado de muerte
entonces ahí vemos diferentes temas que
están confluyendo
sicariato pero también otro tipo de
delitos que como bien lo mencionaba
carlos cierto confluyen a este aumento
de las violencias de la criminalidad
solamente en el dmg que constituyen los
cantones de guayaquil durán y
samborondón las muertes violentas se han
multiplicado por tres en comparación a
lo que era el año 2017 en el año 2017
teníamos 126 muertes violentas en esta
zona manejada por la policía en este de
estas tres de estos tres cantones hacia
861 en el 2022 hasta el 13 de agosto de
igual forma no es el primer hecho o el
evento explosivo único que se ha dado en
la zona ya se han registrado 147 eventos
con artefactos explosivos desde que
inició el año 2022 esto de acuerdo a la
información de la policía obviamente la
mayor parte está concentrado en
guayaquil pero también están otras
provincias del ecuador afectados por
estas acciones como el oro guayas de
esmeraldas y santo domingo
en la justicia asturiana
punto importante para aclarar esa
importancia geográfica de esas
provincias de la costa ecuatoriana karla
su opinión sobre este tema sobre ese
panorama social lo que representan estas
regiones si hay algo para añadir en
frente a lo que decía en carolina y le
prolongó un poco la
pregunta también su gato si quiere
participar
acompañarnos en el debate ya que se mete
en el cuadro de cámara y es en la
situación de tráfico y consumo de drogas
en ecuador normalmente o históricamente
los países latinoamericanos y de
suramérica eran más productores eran
zonas donde se cultivaba la droga y se
producía pero no eran tanto consumidores
ecuador ahora que tanto tiene en ese
porcentaje no de consumo y de productos
bueno producción de nos aclaró carolina
que no es tanto pero que tal el consumo
allí
a ver varias cosas quisiera complementar
un poco lo que dijo carolina que género
o recreo muy bien el panorama pero
quisiera añadir que hay que considerar
que guayaquil fue la zona más golpeada
del ecuador en tanto en cuando ocurrió
la pandemia tuvimos la mayor cantidad de
muertes y la atención sanitaria y la
atención pública más precaria que pudo
tener el resto del país y en relación
también con otros países vivimos una
verdadera masacre digamos donde la gente
tenía que sacar los cuerpos muertos con
kobe a las calles para que para poder
recibir atención no había médicos
forenses no había posibilidad de
enterrar a los muertos es decir vivimos
una verdadera masacre digo vivimos
porque yo estuve viviendo en guayaquil
hasta hace pocos meses entonces es una
ciudad muy golpeada que está con unos
indicadores muy débiles de empleo formal
hay muchísima informalidad poco acceso a
servicios públicos y además hay una
desigualdad muy importante
las riquezas más grandes del país se
encuentran en guayaquil y la pobreza más
grande también la desigualdad juega un
papel muy importante en la en la
criminalidad organizada porque permite
que los sectores más pobres se vinculen
de una u otra manera en este sentido en
claro guayaquil ha vivido una
vulnerabilidad que es histórica también
que ha que viene de muchos años atrás
que durante un tiempo se pudo contener y
después
se pacificó mucho la ciudad pero
nuevamente vemos el repunte de los de
los indicadores esto sumado a que
guayaquil tiene un presupuesto muy
reducido en relación a la capital que es
quitó tiene menos presencia de efectivos
policiales de la fuerza pública una
inteligencia que no está haciendo tan
potente entonces creo que ahí tenemos
como una mezcla explosiva yo resalto
mucho este tema de la responsabilidad
del estado el crimen organizado no
florece donde hay una fuerte
institucionalidad donde hay acciones
preventivas
de una inteligencia adecuada que
permiten hacer el rastreo de las
actividades y tomar decisiones
inteligentes en cuanto al presupuesto y
en cuanto a las estrategias para poder
moderar y contener el crimen en esta
ciudad esto es lo que hace tan
particular la criminalidad en el puerto
de guayaquil en carla que hay de la
articulación entre el gobierno local
entre la alcaldía de cynthia viteri y el
gobierno nacional en quito hay sintonía
hay un buen flujo de comunicación
efectivamente aquí hay un cortocircuito
entre las dos partes entre las dos
autoridades para llevar a cabo planes
efectivos allí en guayaquil
pues estamos en un momento electoral en
febrero del año siguiente del 2023 pues
tendremos elecciones seccionales y
elegiremos alcaldes otra vez esto
significa que el gobierno o el local el
gobierno de la candidata ahora y
alcaldes a cynthia viteri pues está
tratando de marcar una diferencia muy
grande con el gobierno central que ha
perdido legitimidad ha perdido apoyo
social porque no ha sabido responder a
las necesidades del país entonces a esta
cantidad te quiere marcar esta distancia
y claro está en una pelea significativa
con él con el gobierno central diciendo
bueno es su responsabilidad
efectivamente los los o en términos más
teóricos digamos los municipios deberían
apoyar en la construcción de estrategias
de seguridad que permitan y superar la
situación que tenemos pero en términos
prácticos los municipios están con
deudas por parte del estado central que
no paga todas las asignaciones
presupuestarias a las que se comprometió
en unos presupuestos reducidos este es
el caso de guayaquil no tienen todas las
capacidades al tiempo que el gobierno
central se jacta de tener 11 mil
millones de dólares en una reserva
internacional entonces podemos ver que
la inversión o las prioridades de
inversión del gobierno central no están
siendo los gobiernos locales y eso
sumado a la criminalidad que está
subiendo por falta de inversión y por lo
que ya hemos comentado pues lo que
genera es una fuerte tensión entre los
gobiernos locales y el gobierno central
y esto se va a mantener así durante toda
la campaña electoral porque los los
alcaldes los candidatos alcaldes no
quieren estar identificados con el
gobierno central y esto va a
distorsionar la comunicación en carolina
ya lo decían desde quitó algunas
autoridades y personajes políticos de la
vida política ecuatoriana pedían que
estos hechos de violencia recientes en
guayaquil no se convirtieran en temas
electorales pero que tan
efectivo puede ser en este momento
jugarse esa carta de la violencia y la
inseguridad que se está viviendo en el
país para lograr un triunfo electoral y
qué tan importante puede llegar a ser
este tema de verdad como eje central de
las campañas que van a tener de cara a
esas elecciones de febrero del 2023
bueno en la constitución es clara al
decir que las responsabilidades del
estado central ellos son quienes el
estado es quien es el encargado de
garantizar la seguridad integral en el
ecuador entonces no puede evadir sus
responsabilidades este desmantelamiento
esta falta de recursos de capacidades
técnicas humanas y tecnológicas también
es responsabilidad de quienes han
decidido políticamente cómo asignar los
recursos el presupuesto al sector
seguridad el sector salud el sector
social entonces en ese sentido existe
este panorama y obviamente los goles es
una posición un poco cómoda por parte
del estadio del gobierno decir no
politizar el tema mientras la población
no encuentra una respuesta a los temas
de inseguridad tiene miedo tiene temor
es salir en las calles las encuestas a
nivel local y nacional dan muestra de
eso es la principal preocupación que
tienen los ecuatorianos y obviamente
desde los gobiernos locales durante el
periodo electoral tendrán que me imagino
como una parte estrategias justamente
presentar propuestas que de alguna forma
cubran el vacío que ha mostrado el
estado central el gobierno en poder
hacer efectivo su rol en garantizar la
seguridad integral de los ecuatorianos
es un poco como el contexto de la
pandemia que mencionaba carla ante la
ausencia del estado central ante la
ausencia de políticas públicas por parte
del gobierno en muchos casos los
gobiernos locales tuvieron que asumir
esa responsabilidad esas competencias a
pesar no tener todos los recursos
suficientes pero desde lo local
construir algún tipo de salida y
respuesta que pueda en algo generar un
espacio al menos de convivencia pacífica
entre los barrios entre los vecinos y
construir redes de solidaridad no sé
carolina si las cosas que tanta factura
o cobro le va a pasar este tema al
presidente guillermo lasso esta falta de
acción estas críticas estos
señalamientos
estos baños de agua tibia que pone con
un estado de excepción pero que no
enfrentan el problema de raíz como lo
decía yo en la introducción del programa
efectivamente ella es una de más de un
año cuatro meses en que se está pidiendo
que se presente una estrategia de
intervención integral un plan de
seguridad integral políticas claras pero
no hay una respuesta se reconstituyó la
secretaria de seguridad pública del
estado que reemplaza a una institución
que fue eliminada en 2017 entonces no
hay ni siquiera una estabilidad en esas
capacidades y lo que estamos viendo lo
cierto es que el gobierno se ve muy
afectado por la falta de acción y por
esa reacción además desorientada que no
tiene claro quiénes son las estructuras
quienes están ahí y que genera un
programa de recompensas para tratar de
identificar a los involucrados quiere
decir que ni siquiera los organismos de
inteligencia de investigación tienen
claro cómo están funcionando esas
estructuras y cómo afectan las
estructuras los flujos financieros
ilícitos y no concentrarse en generar
resultados vinculados a los eslabones
más débiles entonces claramente esto
genera una afectación en cuanto a la
imagen a la credibilidad a la aceptación
del gobierno nacional en un contexto en
el que el gobierno ya ha perdido gran
parte de su apoyo no olvidemos que cerca
de
ocho de cada diez ecuatorianos cerca de
ocho cada diez ecuatorianos no cree y no
tiene confianza en el gobierno y eso se
siente nuevo mucho más durante el paro o
la movilización que se dio en el mes de
junio claro y creo que ahí el gobierno
tenía el momento no cierto para
replantear sus prioridades para generar
mayor inversión en los sectores sociales
en el sector seguridad y poder dar un
nuevo paso en cuanto a las prioridades y
en la orientación de sus políticas en
carla y su opinión sobre este tema la
factura que le va a pasar al gobierno de
torno este tema y si la situación se
llega a salir de control que es la
extensión que le hago de la pregunta si
este este drama de inseguridad y porque
entendemos cómo es la dinámica de estos
grupos delincuenciales cuando toman
fuerza después es muy difícil frenarlos
y puede llegar a verse escenarios como
están ocurriendo hoy en día en méxico o
en colombia que son tal vez los casos
más críticos en donde hay zonas donde
prácticamente el estado no existe y
quienes están allí ejerciendo casi que
gobernando son los cárteles en
diferentes puntos de las fronteras y de
los puntos estratégicos para el
narcotráfico está guayaquil
a la esquina de verse en una situación
así o por lo menos la costa el pacífico
ecuatoriano
yo creo que estamos ya en una situación
así y no estamos a la vuelta de la
esquina estamos entrando en unos niveles
de violencia que son inéditos en el país
pero que se asemejan mucho a los
escenarios colombianos y mexicanos lo de
la bomba el fin de semana es solo un
evento más hemos visto gente colgada
muertos colgados en puentes peatonales
en avenidas muy concurridas en guayaquil
en la zona costera hemos visto a gente
decapitada y las imágenes de la
violencia carcelaria han sido de una
brutalidad espantosa es decir estamos ya
entrando en una lógica que el país no
había conocido y sobre todo quisiera
llamar la atención sobre el hecho de que
el ecuador como sociedad se ha
construido sobre la imagen y sobre la
identidad propia de ser un país de paz
en relación a las crisis de violencia
que tuvieron pero en los años 80
colombia en los 90 y demás y el ecuador
pues no había vivido esto y entonces
estamos como realmente afectados
la factura es enorme para el gobierno
pero es mucho peor para los ecuatorianos
porque el gobierno saldrá y esta
situación probablemente se empeore por
el mal manejo que ha demostrado la falta
de cuadros capacitados la
desarticulación de las instituciones del
estado la falta de una estrategia para
tener una seguridad integral con cloro
en múltiples dimensiones nosotros vamos
a tener que enfrentar la violencia de
salir día a día la calle de cuidar cada
vez nuestras pertenencias de cuidar
nuestra vida frente a una sociedad que
se descompone y en la que va a ser más
difícil vivir y cuyo tejido social va a
ser muy muy difícil de recomponer
después de todo lo que hemos visto claro
en karla carolina hemos analizado este
problema esta problemática desde
diferentes ángulos he tratado de verlo
desde diferentes aristas ya estamos en
la parte final del programa y quiero
hablar de posibles soluciones esto no se
va a solucionar de la noche a la mañana
ni este gobierno lo va a lograr hace 23
años que le queda en la jefatura del
estado pero hablemos
de pasos a seguir que podrían llevar a
sí y una ruta para que ecuador pueda
lograr enfrentar esta situación y
empezar a dar unos pasos hacia la
mejoría y hacia garantizar la seguridad
y la paz a sus habitantes sobre todo
allá en la zona del pacífico comienzo
entonces con carla para hacer la ronda a
la inversa terminar con carolina
adelante
bueno estrategias hay muchas para hacer
creo que una cosa que no se ha hablado
en este espacio y que es bien importante
decir es que el ecuador está viviendo
además de todas las crisis de
inseguridad una crisis de impunidad
nosotros no tenemos un solo responsable
de las masacres carcelarias no tenemos
identificado quién fue o quiénes fueron
los autores de la bomba o quienes han
matado con una crueldad atroz a la gente
colgada en los puentes a los decapitados
no sabemos todavía no tenemos un juicio
o sentencia sobre las personas que
sabemos que han estado involucradas me
refiero a los oficiales de la fuerza
pública fuerzas armadas y policiales que
no están involucrados con el
narcotráfico que sabemos que han
recibido dinero entonces tenemos una
crisis de impunidad creo que uno de los
elementos centrales para poder revertir
la situación que estamos viviendo es
poner la justicia en orden y poder dar
sentencias adecuadas
en el tiempo correcto también
rehabilitar el sistema penitenciario es
una cosa que se pueda ser muy puntual y
concretamente que no se ha hecho es
necesario empezar a ver la seguridad ya
no sólo desde la lógica policial de
tener más gente más policías en la calle
hay que tener estrategias claras
inteligentes sobre el crimen y hay que
fortalecer la inteligencia estos serían
las recomendaciones a grandes rasgos que
yo daría desde mi perspectiva para poder
revertir
en primera instancia la situación que
estamos viviendo actualmente lucha
contra la impunidad punto clave que a
carla como un paso para comenzar a
mejorar o revertir esta situación
carolina su perspectiva
bueno principalmente definir las
prioridades del interior del gobierno
creo que es importante que se apueste
por la prevención pero no una prevención
solamente con más presencia militar y
policial en las calles sino con una
acción efectiva y una presencia efectiva
del estado en los territorios incluyendo
el sector social con salud educación en
esta inclusión económica y social usted
mencionaba el tema del consumo interno
de hecho en américa latina y el caribe
este cada centro el 24.5 por ciento del
consumo global de cocaína y en ecuador
es uno de los tres primeros países hasta
datos de 2016 como el que cuenta el
último informe de naciones unidas con
mayor consumo también todos tenemos un
problema de salud pública y sin embargo
la respuesta del gobierno solamente es
la represión y el control entonces
necesitamos que amplíe esa visión ni de
la problemática desde un enfoque
integral holístico apuesta a la
prevención ya no podemos vivir en estado
de excepción permanente necesitamos que
se construyan soluciones de mediano y
largo plazo y todo esto debe ir a la par
en fortalecer las capacidades del
sistema de inteligencia en las
capacidades de inteligencia
antidelincuencial que tiene la policía
capacidades técnicas operativas humanas
y también en fortalecer los temas de
investigación pero estos temas de
investigación deben también y ahí
coincido totalmente con carla con el
tema de la impunidad y el tema de
transparencia y los mecanismos de
control de la fuerza pública que se han
visto muy entredicho durante las últimas
semanas me queda un minuto para
finalizar el programa carla carolina
conclusiones rápidamente no tenemos bola
de cristal siempre lo digo al final del
programa no sabemos qué va a suceder con
este tipo de situaciones dábamos unos
pasos o unas propuestas unas ideas de
por dónde empezar a abordarlo pero qué
va a suceder con ecuador- qué va a
suceder con esta región del pacífico qué
va a suceder con guayaquil carolina
ronda la inversa él tiene la palabra
bueno si no hay un cambio de rumbo y de
prioridades lo que veremos un incremento
de violencias que se acerquen mucho más
a los centros urbanos poblados ya lo
estamos observando se lo viene alertando
desde meses atrás que esto podría
suceder sin embargo no ha cambiado nada
lo mismo observamos en dentro de las
cárceles con las masacres carcelarias no
se ha realizado ni siquiera el censo
carcelario no se cuenta con información
actualizada entonces vemos un estado
reactivo y muy tardío no entonces lo que
necesitamos es apostar por una paz
sostenible y ahí la guerra no es contra
el narcotráfico es contra la pobreza y
la desigualdad carla su conclusión para
cerrar el programa
definitivamente lo que dice carolina
necesitamos tener una perspectiva
estructural sobre las condiciones de
violencia y de criminalidad en el país
necesitamos que a la par de pensar en
reducir la criminalidad y la violencia
necesitamos pensar en dar fuentes de
trabajo crear espacios públicos dotar de
salud de alimentación adecuada a la
población el desafío es enorme para el
gobierno en este momento no hay
perspectivas claras de que haya
comprendido la dimensión y la
complejidad de lo que enfrenta en este
momento pero sin embargo hay que tener
como una mirada más allá sólo de la
policialización de la seguridad y hay
que pensar que el hambre también hace
involucrarse a la gente en actividades
ilegales la falta de salud la falta de
espacios adecuados entonces hay que
tener una mirada bastante más compleja
de lo que estamos teniendo ahora pues
con estas palabras de la conclusión de
karla álvarez y también la participación
de carolina andrade en el debate de
france 24 les agradezco a las dos por
haber estado con nosotros en el programa
y por habernos puesto en perspectiva
esta situación está presentando en
ecuador ya lo decíamos la inseguridad
principalmente en el puerto de la ciudad
de guayaquil debido a los grupos
delincuenciales y al narcotráfico en
esta zona del país ustedes pueden seguir
dejando todos sus comentarios y
preguntas a través de las redes sociales
y pueden seguir en sintonía de france24
siguen con nosotros
[Música]